عمران ربما تسير على خطى صعده فبمجرد ان
يتم التوصل الى هدنه هناك بين الحوثيين
ومسلحي القبائل حتى تنهار عند حاجز عسكري
بمنطقه قارن يشترك الحوثيون مع القوات
الحكوميه ثم ت قتلى وجرحى في صفوف الطرفين
والاهم كما قالت المصادر هو قيام الحوثيين
باختطاف دوريتين تابعتين للشرطه العسكريه
والامن العام و استيلائهم على الحاجز
العسكري
ياتي هذا في سياق مساع لجماعه الحوثي لبسط
نفوذها وسيطرتها على مناطق اوسع في شمال
اليمن كما يقول خصومها
وبحسب هؤلاء فان الحوثيين يريدون تكرار
السيناريو صعده في عمران يطالبون باقاله
محافظها وقائدها العسكري باعتبارهما
محسوبين على حزب الاصلاح الاسلامي ولا
يمثل ان ابناء المحافظه لكن خلف هذا
الشعار وهذه المطالبه فانهم يسعون الى
اضعاف قبائل المنطقه وتياراتها السياسيه
لتكون له اليد الطولى في المحافظه
الحوثيون سبق لهم ان دخلوا بسلاحهم الى
عمران و تظاهروا فيها قبل نحو شهر رغم رفض
وحافظ دخولهم بالاسلحه وقبل ذلك وتحديدا
قبل نحو شهرين استولوا على بلدات في
المحافظه واشتبكوا مع قبائل حاشد هناك
وكان هدفهم براي معارضيهم هو التقدم
بخطوات صغيره كل مره تحافظ على ما يعتبر
مكاسب لهم على الارض بينما يقول الحوثيون
ان المشكله هناك سببها من يسمونهم
الجماعات التكفيريه وهو نفس التعبير الذي
استخدم في دماج بصعده حيث انتهى الامر
هناك باخراج المتهمين بالتكفير من المنطقه
وتهجير عائلاتهم منها الحوثيين من قبل ومن
بعد تحفظات على مشروع الدوله الاتحاديه
ويسعون كما يذهب رجال القبائل وساسه
يمنيون الى احكام سيطرتهم على مناطق شمال
البلاد ومنها صعده وعمران وحجه والجوف
وذلك مسعى انفصالي بتفتيت الدوله اليمنيه
كما يقول خصومهم